it's kind of odd seeing you without
Anthony Maggie these days it's nice
isn't it it's just I'm like on a very
different level of like calm like my
heart's like you know he was here though
did you guys hang out I know he was here
no we met we miss each other well you
should ask what Jamie had to go through
with him today
you know look no I I'm gonna see him
though I'm gonna see him a lot we got a
got a long road ahead of us yeah well I
gotta ask because there was a visceral
reaction to Bucky's new short hair yeah
he looks like looks like that might
happen well look it is a bit of a new
book I mean he's got a the guy's got to
go out there and sort of figure out
what's next you know and you know you
wanna you want to change it up you want
to see what the hell is happening but in
a way look I think this is going to be
the closest we're gonna get to him in a
way finding his identity again so it's
sort of it's almost feels like a way
back to the past
you know the forties fifties look and
stuff like that and kind of I think it's
the first time the guys like looking in
the mirror
like you know [ __ ] what happened you
know Here I am again when I got more
wrinkles but or maybe that's just me
remember when they called him white wolf
like it's not gonna come back into play
I don't know I I don't know okay I want
to talk about this movie real quick
because you guys I love a romance first
of all watch any romantic movie I love
the amount of improv that you guys got
to do so how do you think that that
amount almost bummed that you guys
didn't get to see it so will we talk
about it because I'm really curious how
people will resonate with it I mean look
you know you've been in relationships
right like it's like yeah I mean they're
you know I wish that every relationship
that I've been in would be like you know
the way that they are and Love Actually
and in an area Met Sally and you know
all those amazing I'm nodding Hill my
favorite movies ever but they're a
little like darker and Messier and
twisted and they don't always have like
a button at the end and they still rip
you apart and you're still confused if
you made the right choice you know so
there's all these are the colors that I
feel like sometimes you don't get that
you hey that's great particularly really
like hones in on you know and in his
movies which is why I love and so I
think like people will read like will
relates in the movie just just in the
sense of watching and going like you
know I feel like I've had that
conversation or I've been in that
situation or should I answer that text I
don't know but if I wait maybe I'll wait
a day then they'll be cooler you know
like it's like we're all in that wall
yeah we're all in there god help us
[Music]